Film Courage: What makes a great actor?
Robin Riker, Actor/Author: I think a great
actor is someone who can feel as they listen.
Because I think the best moments happen when
you’re not talking.
Your response to another person is something
that can feed them in that just having your
line when it’s your turn to speak doesn’t
you know.
I can see it happen.
I’ve been on both sides of the giving and
receiving of that where you have your moment
and what I do…just what my response is,
what my eyes say, what my body says…I can
see the other person going deeper into what
it is that they want to say because they know
that they are being heard.
And it is a natural kind of symbiotic thing.
A wonderful quote from either Julie Harris
(a fantastic actress) or Helen Hayes (another
fantastic actress), she was doing a play in
Broadway and she had to do it night after
night after night for months and months and
months.
And there is a scene in which she comes downstage
and sits on the park bench and has a moment
and weeps.
And they’re talking about the scene and
what she’s thinking and all that and the
person says to her (the interview says) “How
can you cry every night?”
And she says “How can you not?”
And that was the end of the quote…because
she was in that moment.
She was feeling that feeling.
She was hearing those words or feeling that
feeling and how can you not respond to that
if you’re really hearing?
So that’s what I think makes a wonderful
actor is being able to hear and feel whether
you are talking or not.
Film Courage: Being so dialed in where you
are able to hear something with a fresh perspective
night after night to take you to that place,
but then developing the tough skin to not
let other things that are in the business
you down?
This sounds like an incredible balance?
Robin: Ahhh!
Therein is the rub!
Yes, it is not an easy thing we do, you know?
It’s challenging on so many levels because
so many other people you have a job, you have
a job, you go to that job, you do that job.
This is one of the reasons why the economic
downturn affected me not at all because actors
are always looking for jobs so it’s not
“Oh my Gosh!
I lost my job.”
Because we’re always going from one to another.
But you do have to balance that.
You have to protect yourself from the slings
and arrows of this silly business, of this
capricious business in order to protect your
softy creamy center for when you actually
need it.
Film Courage: Great analogy.